salut quatrième et dernière vidéo sur ce
que cela implique d'être rationnel je ne
reprends pas ce qui était dit avant je
compte sur le fait que c'est assimilé on
a fini par dire que la prise de
conscience de notre activité de
cartographes peut aider à mieux se
comprendre
la carte est faite de croyance et celles
ci sont liées à des désirs donc
comprendre les relations qui se tissent
entre les deux c'est comprendre la
logique de la carte et comprendre la
logique d'une carte
ça semble être plutôt important si on
veut travailler autour des différences
entre nos manières de voir le monde sait
manière de voir le monde sait ce qu'on
peut appeler un point de vue ou une
perspective imaginons une partie de
poker
on pourrait commencer par se mettre
d'accord sur la composition du monde
c'est à dire sur ce qu'on considère réel
ça revient ici et se mettre d'accord sur
la composition du paquet de cartes si on
n'imagine pas la même chose quand on
pense à un paquet de cartes
ça va être compliqué de jouer on
pourrait ensuite se mettre d'accord sur
ce que l'on considère bons et mauvais ce
serait s'accorder sur la valeur des
cartes on peut avoir des préférences
personnelles mais on peut dégager des
consensus
de la même manière que la plupart des
humains s'accordent pour dire qu'il vaut
mieux être en bonne santé et avoir assez
d'argent pour se nourrir
la plupart des joueurs de cartes
s'accordent pour dire qu'un roi vaut
mieux qu 1,8 et puis il y a un objectif
au poker c'est remporter la mise
et c'est objectif est cadré par les
règles du jeu ce qu'on pourrait
apparenter aux lois noter que l'objectif
n'a pas le même sens pour tout le monde
et c'est ça qui est intéressant tout le
monde n'importe pas une partie de poker
avec les mêmes intentions avec la même
perspective
certains jouent gros daphné tente de
rembourser ses dettes
on joue au poker d'autres se
divertissent camille est là pour
s'amuser
d'autres encore viennent avec l'idée de
gagner un peu ils se retireront s'il
parlait enterking somme il ne cherche
pas à remporter la partie
le sens des cartes diffère donc daphné
accueille une mauvaise main avec
tristesse camille avec détachement
ils ne voient pas la même chose pour
camille un ascète une source
d'excitation pour daphné une source
d'espoir camille daphné joue au même jeu
mais le jeu n'a pas du tout le même sens
pour l'un et l'autre le hasard
intervient ici au moins deux fois
d'abord par la distribution
tout le monde ne reçoit pas des cartes
de même valeur tout le monde ne part pas
avec la même chance
ensuite il ya aussi des moyens de départ
la miss n'a pas le même sens pour l'un
et pour l'autre pour daphné cela
représente beaucoup pour camille pas
tant que ça
si la partie de poker n'était pas un
passe-temps parmi d'autres mais la
manière dont on organise la vie en
société on pourrait imaginer un qu'on
adapte les règles pour compenser la
place du hasard car si le hasard pimente
le jeu personne jouer son existence sur
un coup de dés et 2 qu'on se mettre
d'accord sur les objectifs veux-t-on
entretenir un système compétitif où
seule une minorité de joueurs ressortent
gagnants on pourrait décider par exemple
que l'objectif est collectif et non pas
individuelle qu'on veut tous une vie en
bonne santé avec de quoi se nourrir
on va donc tenter de minimiser les
inégalités par exemple on peut ajouter
les mises en fonction des moyens ou
redistribuer les gains ou pipe et la
distribution pour que daphné plus de
chance de tomber sur un aspect camille
on peut étudier les différentes options
possibles
il paraît un peu absurde d'imaginer
qu'il puisse exister quelque chose comme
représentation neutre du paquet de cas
non le monde ne représente pas la même
chose pour chacun d'entre nous comment
disait la carte est politique en ce sens
que sur la carte de daphné un as et
salvateur 1 2 est un danger le monde
n'apparaît pas de la même manière selon
la situation dans laquelle on se trouve
comme on dit dans la vidéo sur la
compréhension
le fantasme de l'accès à une réalité
neutre est un fantasme irrationnel si on
demande à 10 personnes d'écrire une
boule de billard de la manière la plus
neutre possible on recevra des
descriptions différentes et non neutre
dans la mesure où l'ordre par lequel les
informations seront données influencera
l'idée que l'on se fera de la boule bien
sûr cela paraît anodin pour ce qui est
d'une boule de billard mais c'est notre
perception du monde dans son ensemble
qui est définie par la présence de
caractéristiques saillantes
il est très probable que le caractère
saillants dépend de notre point de vue
donc de notre situation dans le monde
certains sont plus sensibles aux
couleurs et d'autres poids peut-on
vraiment arbitrer ce type d'inclination
disons les choses ainsi il paraît assez
intuitive que le désir de justice prenne
en compte la gravité d'une action ainsi
on ne pénalise pas de la même manière
celui qui vole une pomme et celui qui
assassina notre forme on considère la
nuisance du premier acte plus faible que
celle du second des leurs il faut
reconnaître que notre idée de la justice
dépend entièrement de notre conception
de la gravité tout dépend de notre
perception des nuisances quelqu'un qui
perçoit très précisément l'intensité
d'une douleur aura une idée très
différente de celui qu'ils imaginent
approximativement pour ce qui est de
l'importance d'y remédier
si vous souffrez le martyre et que
quelqu'un qui va bien minimise votre
douleur vous aurez les raisons que vous
énerver c'est pareil pour l'ensemble de
nos croyances et notre lecture politique
si on n'a pas accès à une perception
suffisamment fine de ce que cela
représente de vivre avec moins de 900
euros par mois en france on n'est pas
capable de comprendre
affectivement et intellectuellement
l'importance et la gravité de
l'injustice liées aux inégalités de
richesse celui qui se demande s'il va
pouvoir manger à la fin du mois à un
accès privilégié
si vous me permettez l'expression un
certain type d'expérience celui qui
gagne 2000 euros par mois ne peut pas
seul à représenter très précisément
celui qui gagne 5000 euros on est
complètement déconnecté il faut faire un
effort conscient et désagréable pour
sont approchés rien qu'un peu être
rationnel c'est prendre en charge les
différences d'expérience il n'ya pas
l'effet d'un côté et les objectifs de
l'autre comme on aime à le répéter en
invoquant la guillotine de yuma tout
bout de champ l'expérience sensible est
un fait qui varie selon les situations
il faut prendre en compte cette
variabilité pour comprendre le monde
l'émotion joue un rôle prépondérant dans
notre rapport à l'existence il serait
fou de minimiser le désengagement
politique
le désintérêt pour ces questions ce
n'est pas là une attitude neutre c'est
un point de vue permis par une situation
de confort je veux insister sur l'idée
que l' attitude rationnelle n'est pas
une attitude froide et d engager
politiquement parce qu'il n'existe pas
de position neutre paulo freire et le
dit mieux que moi
se laver les mains du conflit entre les
dominants et les dominés c'est se placer
du côté des dominants et non pas être
neutre
le premier devoir rationnelle c'est
d'interroger la morale et le système de
valeurs par défaut qu'on a adopté à
cause de notre culture de notre
environnement de notre situation il faut
produire consciemment des efforts pour
se demander quelles sont mes valeurs
morales et comment est ce que je compte
les soutenir si on était pas ce travail
là on se laisse aller à soutenir le
système en place
on agit porté par son inertie ma
deuxième règle d'or attaché à la
première et aristotéliciennes posons
explicitement le telle hausse
demandons nous individuellement et
collectivement quelle vie désirons nous
pour nous mêmes et pour les autres
individuellement ça permet de comprendre
pourquoi on agit comme ont agi
collectivement c'est un pré requis pour
construire un meilleur monde
poser ces questions c'est éviter les
problèmes majeurs que soulève l'enjeu
politique pour la rationalité comme dit
woods causes qui en politique
les arguments sont des soldats on
soutient tous ceux qui vont dans notre
sens
ils sont au front une se battent pour
nous questionner leur pertinence ce
serait comme les abandonnés ou pire les
poignarder dans le dos c'est le problème
du jugement par contamination ou
solidarité je dois refuser ce que dit
mon adversaire et soutenir ce que dit
mon allié sinon je risque d'affaiblir
notre position on présume une cohérence
globale si c'est mon adversaire qu'il
dit je dois être en désaccord
si c'est mon allié qui le dit alors je
dois être d'accord ça génère de la
confusion d'autant que noah ristic
fonctionnent comme des radars on vit les
arguments et notre radar bip
selon les associations que l'ont fait
spontanément pour certains libre
circulation des idées fait sonner
l'alarmé néolibéralisme pour d'autres
sciences sociales fait sonner l'alarmé
gauchiste mais ce n'est pas parce qu'un
argument ressemble à un argument que je
refuse contexte y qu'il est
automatiquement problématique dans un
contexte x c'est seulement en clarifiant
de telos en mettant en clair ce qu'on
vise qu'on peut évaluer les arguments et
les idées il faut identifier le trésor
pour pouvoir débattre du meilleur chemin
à emprunter une grosse question étant
évidemment quels trésors vis ton ça peut
être un trésor personnel ou un trésor
collectif mais en tout cas ça ne peut
pas être neutre politiquement il faut
aussi que ce soit un trésor réaliste
c'est à dire quelque chose qu'on peut
effectivement obtenir et qui représente
une différence pratique c'est pour ça
qu'on disait faire du mieux qu'on peut
avec ce qu'on a
ça commence donc par identifier ce qu'on
a est ce qu'on a c'est précisément ce à
une carte qu'on dessine en continu
depuis la naissance et qui est un
mélange compliqué et en partie aveugle à
lui-même de croyances et de désir
ensuite il faut reconnaître que les
sources à disposition sont toujours
limités la limite de nos ressources
concerne bien sûr les moyens à
disposition pour atteindre les objectifs
mais aussi notre manière de faire la
carte ce qui concerne tout aussi bien la
fiabilité de nos croyances et la
transparence de nos désirs notre
aveuglement relatifs à nos propres
sources de motivation est un exemple de
limitation du travail rationnel
je crois que j'avance dans telle
direction pour répondre à un tel désir
mais je crois qu'il est possible qu'un
autre désir inconscient oriente
consignes ans mon cheminement
donc il faut garder à l'esprit que notre
carte et le choix du trésor nous échappe
tout
en partie est rationnel ça veut dire
qu'on ne réfléchit pas dans l'absolu pas
dans un monde binaire du tout ou rien
pas dans une expérience dualiste du face
à face avec la réalité pas dans un
fantasme de transparence et de maîtrise
de l'esprit vis-à-vis de lui-même faire
du mieux qu'on peut avec ce qu'on a
c'est optimiser des moyens à disposition
et c'est éviter l'excès de confiance à
tout prix et l'envers de ça c'est éviter
l'excès d'exigence par exemple on ne
jette pas une théorie éthique parce qu
elle est imparfaite
c'est injuste vu qu'on est encore jamais
trouvé de théories morale parfaite on
accepte de viser le moins mauvais on vit
donc la moins mauvaise carte aux trésors
possible c'est-à-dire contente
d'optimiser le continuum croyances désir
les moins un vrai désir relativement à
nos croyances et les moins mauvaises
croyances relativement à nos désirs
c'est un peu une histoire
d'investissement on essaye de
rentabiliser nos efforts il faut que ce
soit le moins coûteux possible
on met à l'épreuve nos décisions en
fonction de ce qu'elle demande et de ce
qu'elles peuvent potentiellement
rapporter
et même si le vocabulaire économique
peut paraître un peu cynique il faut
imaginer que nous sommes souvent
concernés par ce désir de rentabilité
c'est vrai en sciences
si pour résoudre un problème une théorie
en soulève d'autres on la considère a
peut-être trop coûteuse
c'est vrai dans les relations humaines
on cherche un équilibre si on investit
beaucoup dans une relation et que celle
ci nous rend malheureux on peut
considérer changer quelque chose
c'est vrai dans le moindre choix si j'ai
un peu envie d'une bière fraîche mais
qu'il faut faire un kilomètre pour aller
en chercher peut-être que je vais
trouver que ça ne vaut pas le coup
attention on peut avoir envie de
répondre mais attends attends c'est pas
une vie d'être constamment en train de
chercher à rentabiliser tous nos choix
toutes nos actions
c'est un argument qui peut se défendre
mais du coup on a redéfini l'objectif et
ça suppose un nouveau processus
décisionnel s'il nous faut ton être
davantage insouciants à l'heure
l'objectif de la rentabilité n'est plus
rentable car il fait obstacle à notre
objectif de légèreté et du coup on sait
dans quoi on s'embarque mes choix ne
sont peut-être pas rentable quand on les
regarde et une échelle locale
mais ce qui est rentable c'est
l'attitude générale de spontanéité qui
fait que je suis plus heureux c'est pour
ça qu'il faut se demander ce que l'on
veut par exemple pour éviter de
s'embarquer dans des chaînes d'action
pas du tout optimale ce que quand tu
appelles les actions hétéronome
en somme quand je veux x pour obtenir y
pour obtenir z lors que si j'avais eu à
l'esprit que je voulais z
j'aurais pu me demander à quel point x y
sont nécessaires pour y parvenir
c'est une confusion entre la fin et
moyens le cas classique c'est celui qui
croit que c'est le succès professionnel
qui va le rendre heureux
donc pour conclure nous sommes tous
rationnelle si l'on considère qu'être
rationnelle c'est se faire une idée de
la réalité et prendre la bonne décision
pour atteindre nos objectifs
par exemple on peut considérer que
lorsque j'identifie que j'ai soif et que
je me lève sans réfléchir pour prendre
un verre d'eau j'ai agi rationnellement
mais le vrai problème est celui de
l'échelle si je ne devais même pas les
relations entre croyances et désir qui
sont au fondement de ma carte
un choix peut sembler bon à l'échelle
locale alors qu'il est mauvais si on
considère le tout et vice versa en ce
sens être rationnel c'est ne jamais
s'autoriser à croire que notre carte est
pure ou que notre quête est désintéressé
c'est ne jamais oublier qu'on est tous
pris dans une perspective est que nous
n'avons pas grand chose à son propos
donc le mieux que l'on puisse faire
c'est explicite et nos objectifs trouver
des points de convergence entre nos
objectifs et ceux d'autrui et identifier
des moyens d'atteindre ses objectifs
comme c'est du boulot je reconnais mais
en même temps qu'est ce qu'on ait
d'autres affaires merci